so you're going to want to experiment
with different types of media so it's
not just a simple text ad think video
for example video can perform really
well in a social campaign everybody
remembers the ALS ice bucket challenge
right the ice bucket challenge is
something that went absolutely viral and
generated a ton of money for a charity
organization because it was something
that felt real and fun and it wasn't
just a very stale text ad i will say
never go into it with the goal of
creating a viral video that's a recipe
for disaster you always want to create
something that you think is a really
great piece of compelling content so I
think YouTube is a really cost-effective
place for any small business or start up
to and to start promoting their business
I think YouTube is a place where people
go and search and try to figure out our
business is legitimate and you know how
do I use this business or what is this
business all about so YouTube can be a
great place where users will discover
your product and and also where you can
quickly explain your value proposition
so I've seen really creative fifteen to
thirty second YouTube videos where we're
a business we'll just really quickly
explain who they are maybe even a quick
navigation of their site or app and then
a call to action so let's say you know
you want someone to just download your
app today I would you know explain your
value proposition what what a user needs
to know about your business what sets
you apart from any other competitor then
maybe and showing the best case scenario
how a user would use your app and you
know make sure the app navigation is
easy and very clear show that on the
video and then and make it clear that
the call to action is download the app
today and start using your product so
YouTube YouTube is just a great platform
for you to to explain who you are and to
do it simply and easily and really
capture an audience so once you have
that video that you
is just very clear and who you are and
what you can offer then you can start
using it as an ad format so you can use
that video to be placed in youtube
search results as well as and before
other videos so those are what we call
in-stream ad formats or in stream
youtube videos and that also is an
auction and so it's very similar in
principle and how you set up the
campaign but the great thing is you can
use that that captivating video as an ad
to explain who you are and capture users
while they're on youtube so true view is
what we call the ad formats on YouTube
that our auction base so these are ads
that and that you get to decide how much
you're willing to bid for a view of your
video and the great thing is you only
pay when a user views your video and so
you can place your ad before other
videos maybe you want to make sure the
content is similar we could go back to
the travel example so if I'm searching
for great places to travel and then I
have let's say you're a hotel app and so
maybe your ad you want to place your
video ad before I watch a video about
this hotel resort I'm gonna I'm gonna go
check out okay so you can target you
know your ads based on theme or
categories and so then when your ad
shows before the video the user then has
a choice to skip the ad or watch the
full ad ideally the ad is only about 15
or 30 seconds and but you only pay when
a user watches 30 seconds of the video
or the full full length of the video so
if your video is only 15 seconds and a
user gets to the 15-second mark that's
when you pay per view but if the user
wants to skip after two or five seconds
they have the choice to skip the ad and
what's great about this ad format is
that your only capturing users
that are engaged that actually want to
watch this ad that are actually
interested in your product and the rest
you didn't even have to pay for so maybe
they did watch 10 seconds and maybe
they'll think about you later but you
don't actually have to pay for that view